so I'm building up a cable to load a
program which might as well expect you
at the moment I've got a stereo jack -
Jack I stole off Dave's desk so we gave
and I'm just about to modify it to be
more like one of these will carry ground
we need to work out which one it is
there we go so let's try loading this in
now nothing coming out there till now
nope let's make it better
amplify tape loading error right let's
try again
maybe not quite so loud there we go
so Oh looking for yep we've got a QR
code yet oh yeah so we end up going to
the fictional computer games company and
you can see the game's Netflix released
special interactive movie of their TV
series black mirror that started on
channel 4 by Charlie Brooker called
Bandersnatch and for people I mean for
people like Sean who's filming this it
was set in the 1980s so there's a real
sense of nostalgia one thing that was
interesting is he he selected one
particular set of endings you could get
to a point where the main character will
be selecting a tape put it into play and
you would hear a noise like this
and for some people they're sort of
thing that well I said like modems
starting up but for people who sort of
grew up in the UK in the 80s that was
very much instantly recognizable as the
loading sound for the ZX Spectrum which
was a computer I had as a child so we
thought we'd try and load that in and
see what it did we spent about two hours
trying to actually get that to actually
load in basically because the volume
level coming out of the Apple laptop the
world's most expensive tape recorder for
the ZX Spectrum wasn't loud enough for
the ZX Spectrum to lock on to the actual
signal and load the program in time so
we thought it'd be an interesting thing
because we haven't covered it before
we've looked at how disks worked and
things to actually talk about how
computers in the late 70s early 80s used
standard audio cassette tapes to store
data so you would it's certainly in the
UK more perhaps than in the US but over
here most people will be buying the
software on cassette and loading it
enough a domestic tape recorder means
that they're expecting you plug your
standard tape recorder in commodore 64
and some of the Amstrad ones were
slightly different in that they had
dedicated data sets or other data
quarters I think they called it on the
spectrum plus 2 version which were built
in or dedicated for using on the
machines which sold a few issues as we
like we had here let's see how we'd
actually load something in I've got to
use this one with the built-in cassette
recorder purely because of the amount of
Tribble that we had getting it to load
reliably I think using the built-in one
where we're loading or financial tape
makes a bit more sense
excuse the Heath Robinson Asst of the
set up here don't have the cables
anymore so much and I'm just going to
rewind the tape that so we're now loaded
up the ZX spectrum and we've covered
that before this is the more advanced
128k model there's that expression 48k
model will just come up more or less
like this and say to load the program
you type load quote quote hit return and
then you would start the tape and the
same procedure
would work on something like the
commodore 64 with a few variations you
type things slightly differently
depending on what machine it was so
hopefully in a minute it'll start
getting some signal so what's actually
happening now not a lot as i say i'm
users taping about thirty seventh years
what are the stripy lines mean the
stripy lines are just a visualization of
the data that's coming off we then get a
program title and it's now loading in
the program these striper lines down
here are actually a representation of
the data as it's being loaded in off
tables or stored as an audio signal so
that noise you can hear is the date of
the bits to represent the program
converted into audio tones which are
then loaded in by the computer and so
the program would then load it and it
would take a while for these programs to
those and the speed these things worked
often particularly high and we can sort
of see that so taking probably about
three or four minutes for your game to
load or more likely if you using your
domestic tape recorder onto all of the
other things you'd get to the end you
would say our tape loading error and you
have to rewind adjust the volume and
start again which is sort of the
problems we were having when trying to
load the one from the end of the
Bandersnatch movie into the system but
we did get it working there cuz that's
it loaded then is it ready to play no
still loading so it took a while to load
the game in but similar procedures and
you've got similar sort of screens on
those machines you didn't necessarily
get the sort of weird graphics around
the background that was a spectrum thing
although the Commodore 64 sometimes did
similar things when it was loading
software in as well but this was
definitely yeah so the feature with his
LX spectrum games now loaded we can
barely see what's going on pressing a
key to start W to increase angle Q to
decrease angle Aaron P to rotate the
club enter to play the shot but you just
have some sort of resemblance to what
you might class is crazy go so let's
time I think about what's going on when
we load something so what's happening is
is actually very simple the way that the
spectrum generated the signal that went
out onto tape is that it had an output
part of its computer which you could
either
to be +5 volts or we could have it being
zero volts and the computer could change
this to create different patterns if it
oscillates that between the two things
it effectively creates a square wave
which if you then played it would sound
like a tone that sounds familiar to
anyone who was using a Selleck spectrum
so what the computer could do is it
could alternate between a positive value
and zero volts to create a waveform
which could create sounds and so when it
was saving the data you've got a series
of bits you can lay out one after the
other say you were to say about a
thousand bytes that's 8 bits per byte
that's 8,000 bits yet one after the
other so we can write that and we need
to basically take that and send it out
as an audio signal so now you might
think well okay I will just send them
it's 1 0 1 0 1 0 and send it out across
there well if you did that you would
send the data across than another
computer could receive it but when you
wrote it out onto an audio cassette you
probably wouldn't be able to receive the
data again so we need to do is either
modulating to convert it into actual
tones that are audio tones like you
would if you're recording speech or
music and so on you also need to be able
to sort of get started and get into the
actual program know where it starts know
it ends then what happens data is going
on on zenneck spectrum your program
would begin with a block all of the same
frequency if you look at the code for
the operating system you can see that
this works at around 810 Hertz and when
you load a program the computer can see
that and it sees that oscillating signal
about that frequency it says ok I'm now
coming to the point where I'm going to
start loading in a program and it locks
on to that knows that it's now expecting
something at the very end of it there is
a very special t-shaped pulse which is a
different shape then knows that it's
reached the end of the leader so you get
this leader and it knows it's reset and
they then those at the bits that follow
are going to be data and so we then get
a very small chunk if I memory so it's
about 17 bytes which is a header which
describes the program so if we go back
to rewind the cassette first of all when
it starts to flashing between red and
blue that's when it's locked onto the
leader so it knows that it's found the
thing and there we get this bit here we
just pause it for a second it's saying
program golf so it's loaded in the
header and that head has told the
computer that this is a program which
means it's a basic program so it tells
you what type of file is is it a program
which is a basic program is a machine
code or data is it specific type of data
so that's telling us what it is it tells
us how big it is and where it's going to
be loaded into memory depending on what
type of data it is so it Loza that's all
in the header and when you type load you
can either say load quote quote which
will load in any file or you can load a
specific file that if it doesn't matter
static wait until it finds an X header
that tells you what it is there and
there's another byte here hidden in the
header which tells us whether it's a
header or whether it was data and then
we get another bit of leader again or
the same tone but it's much shorter and
again that's of exactly the same purpose
it enables our computer to get into
think with this you get that synched
pulse at the end to say this is finished
so if we restart it it starts to loading
the leader and now it's loading in the
program and this bit of the section
could be of various lengths we don't
know and it's just the data or the
program so these two sections here
they're not made of a one tone but
they're made up of two different tones
and so you either have a tone that is
sort of this length sort of shape or you
have one which is twice as long so we
send this if it's a zero we send this if
it's one and so we get one complete wave
form and what the computer can then do
is when it's loading it back if you get
the volume levels right it takes the
audio signal which isn't really which is
a beta for lots of gross more fragments
of different frequencies either zero or
one to make up the prime once it's
loading them back in it can count the
number
wedges it sees within a specific time
and work out whether there's enough
edges for it to be a zero or has there's
enough edges for it to be a 1 and then
reconstruct the data that's being loaded
in and there's a few bits of parity in
there and other things so that you can
check whether it loaded or correctly or
not when it gets to the end but it's
unable to sort of process the data as
the signals coming in saying why I've
seen this edge of seeing this edge of
seeing this edge that means it should be
zero I'll write a zero into memory it
should be a warn other while as a 1 into
memory and load the data back in now
obviously when you're doing this you
want to make sure that your system is
stable and one of the problems with
cassette tape business as a recording
medium it wasn't that stable if your
battery started too often the pitch of
the music you were listening to would
drop because it was linked to the power
and so on and that was fine for music
because most of time is imperceptible
and you wouldn't notice the while and
flutter as it's called for a computer
program that's a real problem so what
people did
well what Sinkler I did when they
designed this is they chose values for
how long those pulses were going to be
whether it was a 0 or 1 to B such that
if there was one flutter the computer
would be able to K but if it was
slightly faster or slightly slower and
still be able to cope with the data
Kumada actually went slightly further if
we turn on the c6 before they actually
stored two copies of the program one
after the other one they recorded so
when you saved your program out it would
write out the program and then
immediately after that as a separate
block would write out the program again
similar technique using a series of long
pulses and short pulses to represent the
zeros and ones so when we load in a
program on the commodore using its data
set and it will start loading in it
would load the program in and if there's
any errors in there we'd make a note of
where they were within the program and
then when the second copy is played
through it could load in hopefully
correctly from that point the bits that
had gone wrong and sort of correct the
errors and was able to sort of recover
your program you mentioned that they're
given a memory address to then things
just sequentially follow on from there
I mean it seems to me that memory
addresses a long bit of data in it so my
memory just describes where the first
byte goes and so what happened is that
you get a memory address and it would
say load it in here let's say was a
screen on the cell experiments they
loaded in at one six three eight four in
memory so the computer would load in the
first eight bits one after the other
falling them into a byte in one of the
registers and then write that back by
Counting memory at one six three eight
four then loading the next eight bits
from tape and like that out into memory
that bits one six three eight five and
so on until it loaded in the whole bit
of data and you how many bikes to work
in the case was screen six thousand nine
hundred and twelve and it could load
them in to the right places
interestingly these loading and saving
routines were completely written in
software and if you actually look at the
implementations and the ROM chips each
path that the program can go down has
been correctly sort of worked out to
take the exactly the same number of CPU
cycles so that when it produces the
pulses between the two they're all of
exactly the same length so they're all
of exactly the right frequency and you
produce the data that you need and when
it's loading it again it's counting so
that it can knows exactly how many edges
have been found in a particular point in
time so you have to turn things like
interrupts off it's a bit like when we
talked about writing software for the
2600 these routines are very carefully
written the downside of them is both on
the c64 and on the aesthetic spectrum is
that they took a long time to load in
the program and so what people did
particularly commercial software houses
when they're writing software is that it
would write fast loaders or turbo
loaders and all they do is as they
rewrote the routines that were loading
the program to write load the data
faster so they'd use shorter periods for
one short periods for a0 which meant you
get more in the same amount of time and
so you could then load the program in
faster the downside was is that any sort
of vowel flutter variations in volume
and so on would make the program harder
to load now from the commercial software
houses point of view that wasn't
actually a problem because they could
bit right these tapes out using
professional equipment that would
a strong signal onto the tape which
would load and work fine you then try
and copy that cassette by connecting to
cassette recorders together the copy
wouldn't then low which is great because
it meant you had to go out and buy the
real copy and so it actually has a
benefit in terms of anti piracy things
but also made it so the game load you
didn't say two minutes rather than three
minutes whatever it was I think the
Commodores given up hasn't it yeah well
I mean it's not a deck spectrum is it
going back to the sort of file that was
attached to the end and Bandersnatch
after lots of jiggery-pokery twiddling
wires together and finding a the right
volume we managed to get the program
loaded into that expectrum and when you
run it
it's a program written by Matt Westcott
on behalf of Netflix last year to
display a QR code on the screen so it
basically it runs the program it draws a
QR code there's lots of nice visual
effects to make it look like it's
playing off an old piece of videotape
with occasionally looking like it's on a
sony tv that's lost lock the amazing
thing is if you follow that QR code
you've taken to the took us off the
fictional website out of the movie and
you can actually download one of the
games that's mentioned in there you can
get a file and you can then play into a
ZX spectrum and actually play one of the
games so the amazing thing is when was
the last select spectrum game written
2018 it seems now I've got the token so
I can load a value in add the bay leaf
emerged or into it and store it back and
hand the token and now I've got the
token again I can load something into it
into my register add something onto it
sew it back and pass the token on and
I've got it so I can load the value in
add the value from a register story back